So, um, we continue the topic of secret
societies and we're going to focus on
their secret weapon, which is mind
control. They're able to turn you into a
programmable robot that they can use as
a weapon.
Um, but before I start that, let's
review what we discussed last class.
This is a class of ideas and concepts.
So it's really important you understand
these concepts because we will build on
them throughout the semester. Okay. So
last class we discussed the
transformation of religious worldview
during the course of western history. So
at first there was the mother goddess
then transition to polytheism
then monotheism.
And
during this transition, the way that our
minds perceived the world radically
changed in three aspects. The first is
that
before we understood that mind led to
matter. So the universe is just one
giant mind that vibrates. Okay? And the
intersection of these vibrations creates
atoms. Then that leads to matter. Okay.
But today in science class, you're
taught that's the opposite. It's the
brain that creates the mind.
And as you will discover throughout the
semester, this conception that the brain
creates the mind. It's very problematic.
Okay? So we will discuss this throughout
the semester. Okay. The second big
difference is before we understood the
world metaphorically.
Okay. So we saw that the world was
controlled by these forces that we could
not see and feel but they were there and
we gave names to them the gods. Now it's
all literal. In science class you're
taught that if you don't see it, it
doesn't exist. If you cannot measure it,
it does not exist. The third big
difference is that before we were
intuitive. We trusted our heart. We
trusted our eyes. But today in science
class, you're taught to not trust your
eyes. You're taught to trust the data,
the tools, the theory. So today is
counterintuitive.
And this is why school is so hard.
Okay? We humans are learning machines.
That's what we're designed to do. To
learn, to absorb, to adapt. But school
is hard because you're taught ideas that
go against your own intuition.
Okay. So these are the main concepts
that we learned last class. So now I
want to talk about mind control. Okay.
So um let's go back to the four earliest
civilizations. These are mass societies.
So these four societies that first came
into being are China.
Uh the Indis Valley civilization, the
Harapen civilization which is now
northern India, Mesopotamia
which today is Iraq and of course the
last one is Egypt.
And of course, Egypt was for thousands
of years the most powerful, the
wealthiest, the most influential. Now,
when you have a mass society, your
biggest problem is social control. How
do you
control the population? How do you get
everyone to get along? And in each
society, they have different solutions.
Okay? So, in China, we develop a
bureaucracy.
And what underpinned the bureaucracy of
course is something called the kju which
is the civil service examination. So
everyone's attention everyone's energies
was focused on getting their child to
pass the ku to become an official and
that's what gave China social stability.
And guess what guys it's still around
today. to that we call the gao okay but
it's the same system no difference at
all
>> the IVC industization created religion
and what's remarkable about the religion
is it is one that preach egalitarianism
equality as well as peacefulness
and their religion becomes the prototype
for Buddhism today okay so what the
religion was puto Buddhism and for the
longest time The IVC was peaceful,
egalitarian. It was a very prosperous
society. Mesoptitania, the solution was
war. The difference between
Mesopotitania and other places is that
there are no natural defenses. In China,
we have mountains, deserts, seas to
protect China. But in Mesopotamia, it's
a desert. And so, it's really easy to
attack. And therefore they had centuries
of warfare and that's what kept the
society together because they were
always at war with each other. And with
Egypt the solution was the
Pharaoh,
right? So
Egypt is unique in that they believe the
Pharaoh was God and therefore everyone
had to obey their God. The problem
though is that the pharaoh was not God.
And as a human in charge of an empire,
his life was always at risk. Okay. So
now I'm going to ask you a question.
What does it take to be a great leader?
In school, you're taught what skills do
you need to be a great leader? Just
shout out the answers.
>> Leadership.
>> Leadership skills. But what are they?
What are they? Responsibility, right?
How about what else?
Wisdom.
>> Openness.
Empathy.
>> Excuse me.
>> Respect.
>> Regret.
>> Respect. Yeah. What else?
Knowledge. Right.
>> Okay. This is what you're taught in
school. And we can go on for a long
time. Okay. There are hundreds of skills
you need to be a great leader. Guess
what guys?
Wrong. Okay. To be a great leader in the
world in history, you need three skills.
And if you just analyze what the leaders
of today are like, it will make sense to
you. Okay. So, Putin, Trump, every
leader in the world shares these three
skills.
Okay. The first is unpredict
predictability.
People cannot predict how you will
behave. You are a mystery to people.
That's the first skill. Second skill is
high stress tolerance.
So Donald Trump is probably the most
hated man in America. Guess what guys?
He goes to bed and he sleeps like a
baby. He does not care.
Okay? He gets up and he's tweeting. He's
giving speeches. He's talking to
reporters. He's the happiest man alive.
He does not care. And so, so the last
skill is lack of empathy.
He does not care what happens to other
people. All he cares is about himself.
And guess what guys? To do well in life,
you need these three skills.
Unpredictability. No one knows how you
think. No one knows how you behave. High
stress tolerance. You don't care. Lack
of empathy. You're very selfish. Okay?
And these are the three skills that
leaders need in order to uh do well. But
you know what? We can just use one word
to describe all three skills. The word
we can use is dissociation.
Dissociation just means that your mind
is part of your body. When you
dissociate, what what literally happens
is your mind leaves your body so that
you don't think that what's happening is
happening to you. It's happening to
someone else. It's like you become an
observer in a movie. Okay? You're in the
movie, but you're also watching the
movie. And this is what leads to these
three things. Unpredictability, high
stress tolerance, and lack of empathy.
Okay.
Um, another word for dissociation that
we use is multiple personality disorder.
Donald Trump is so unpredictable because
he's literally
a 100 different people in a different
circumstance. He's a different person.
And that's why you can never actually
predict how he will behave. And all the
great leaders in history were like that.
Okay. So let me use game theory
to explain why this is the case. Okay.
Game theory.
So in game theory, we discussed before
how when you have a game where there are
millions of different players, okay,
the secret to winning this game is
cheating and you do that by forming
secret alliances,
right? So these three do it. The problem
is this is actually pretty obvious. We
understand this rule. So guess what? A
lot of people form secret alliances.
Okay.
So to win this game, if you want to win
this game, you have to be part of as
many powerful secret alliances as
possible. You have to be the
intersection of these
groups. Okay? So you're here, but you're
also here. You're also here. Okay. But
as we discussed pre previously, these
secret societies have developed systems
to make you loyal, to make you obedient,
to make sure that you will never betray
them. So the only way around this
problem is to create multiple
personalities,
right? Because literally
you're a different person
in a different circumstance and
therefore they're never able to figure
out what you really think. Spies have
the skill. Okay. When spies are being
recruited,
um the one skill that they're looking
for is dissociation. Is this person able
to quickly dissociate from who he is?
Lack of empathy, basically. They're all
psychopaths basically. Okay. So in real
life in a game it's a person with the
most multiple personalities that wins
out. The problem though is when we we go
back to Egypt the pharaoh is born in
that position. So now the question is
are you able to take a person and create
multiple personalities with from that
person?
And the answer is yes. Okay. So I'm
going to show you how.
By by the way, the word we use for this
is psychopath. Okay.
All right. If you have multiple
personalities, you're a psychopath.
All right. So I'm going to show you how
they do this in Egypt. Remember, a
pharaoh is born into that position. And
so now the priests who control the
pharaoh, they have to train that priest
to have multiple personalities. The the
mystery today is how would they do this?
And again, we don't know, but I'm
speculating how they would do this.
Okay. So, if you look at mythology,
Egyptian mythology is different from all
other world mythologies. There's Greek
mythology, there's Chinese mythology,
there's Babylonian mythology, but Egyp
Egyptian mythology, it's unique. Okay?
So, I'm I'm going to explain to you the
basic contours of the mythology. Very
simple. So, there are three main
characters in the mythology. There's
Rah, the sun god. There's Osiris.
And there's Horus.
Okay, these are the three main gods that
Egyptians worship. Rah is what gave life
to the universe. He's a sun god. Osiris
is the god of civilization. He built
Egypt. Okay? And then Horus is the god
of kingship of empire. He's the one who
brings stability to the throne. Okay. So
there are different stories associated
with Rah, Osiris, and Horus. Rah, what
he does is every night he goes into the
underworld and he fights the serpent,
Opthus.
Every night, Opus, the serpent, he's
trying to swallow the sun to prevent the
sun from rising. So Ra must kill him
every night. Okay? And there are
different ways that he kills Oythus.
Sometimes he stabs
Oythus with a knife. Sometimes he uses a
lance. Sometimes he burns
Opthus. Okay? Sometimes he strangles
Oythus. But there are different ways
that he kills Opus. But rest assured, he
kills Opthus every single night so that
the sun can rise in the morning. If one
day
uh Ra doesn't defeat Oythus, well, you
have a solar eclipse. Okay, the sun
cannot rise. But rest assure Ra will
defeat him eventually. Okay, eventually
Ra gives birth to Osiris. And Osiris is
a great pharaoh. But his brother Seth,
Seth, it's pronounced Seth, okay? But
it's it's spelled Seth. Um he is
jealous. He wants a throne. So he tricks
Osiris. One day he says to Osiris,
"Look, I built a tomb and this tomb is
really comfortable."
And so Osiris, "Oh, let me try." So
Osiris jumps in the tomb and he's like,
"Wa, it's really comfortable." And of
course, Seth then closes the tomb and
then throws the tomb away. Now,
now good news is that is Osiris has has
a smart wife. He's pretty dumb, but but
Isis is pretty smart. So Isis is now
looking for Osiris and Seth's like, "Oh,
I can't allow Isis to find Osiris." So
Seth cuts Osiris into a million pieces.
Okay, so uh tomb. And then he cuts up
Osiris and throws Osiris all around the
world. But Isis is committed. So Isis
goes around the world and finds all the
pieces and reassembles
him. Okay. But he but she knows that
eventually Set will find them again. So
he she has sex with him really quickly
which gives birth to Horus and Horus is
wants the throne back. So he goes to war
with Set and they have a series of
challenges. Okay. And some of these
challenges include drowning.
So what they do is they turn each other
into hippos. They go into the bottom of
the river and they see who can hold the
breath the longest. They drown each
other. Okay. Basically, but also um
there's a challenge where set can you
see this word? Okay. R A P E. Okay. He
will do this to Horus because it's a
sign of domination. But eventually Horus
wins out and he becomes the pharaoh.
Okay. So this is the main structure of
Egyptian mythology. And as you can see,
it's really weird. Okay? And it doesn't
make really make sense as a story. It's
not a great story, but if you don't see
it as a story, but as a script, it makes
a lot more sense, right? It's not
something to be believed. It's something
to be acted out. Okay? Why? Because in
Egyptian religion, in the religion, the
pharaoh is a literal reincarnation of
Rah, Osiris, and Horus.
And when you act these things out, you
become the gods because you have their
memories.
Okay? So, how? Let me explain this.
Okay? I I know you'll be confused by
this, but let let me explain. So, let's
go back to Kant. What Kant tells us is
that
there are something called the nomina
which is the things in themselves. We
can never know the things in themselves.
We can never know true reality. We can
only know the phenomena which is the
things we see. In other words, we cannot
differentiate between what is true and
what is false. So if you're able to
control our experience, you're able to
control our memories. Okay. So, let me
give you another example of this.
Remember Monkey Island?
On Monkey Island, we we discussed this
previously. 100 people are transported
onto an island um randomly and they have
to survive millions of flesh-eating
monkeys. And this experience makes them
strong, wise, and united. They're
transported back to the real world, and
together they conquer the world
together. But now the challenge is how
do I ensure that my children and my
grandchildren and my grandchildren
inherit my legacy?
And the answer is through ritual.
Okay? So what you do is you take your
children, you put them on an island and
you tell them a story and then you give
them psychedelics.
Psychedelics
are drugs that enhance your experience.
So you actually believe the story is
happening to you. Okay? It's like being
put into a movie. Okay? And then you
have these rituals that make you believe
that you actually experienced this
yourself.
Okay?
So this is what we call programming.
And this is the great secret of the
human brain. Every human brain can be
programmed in a certain way. Okay, so
let's go back to the story. What's going
on here? This is a recipe for
programming the pharaoh into separate
identities. All three of these
individuals, Rah, Osiris, Horus,
represent different identities. Rah
represents the virtuous
hero, right? Osiris represents the
passive victim
and Horus represents the vengeanceful
child.
Okay,
does that make sense? Okay. So,
by doing these different rituals, I can
get the pharaoh to believe he's a
different person in different
circumstance.
So, while the pharaoh is drugged up, the
pharaoh is dressed up as Ra and he will
take an effigy or a real person and he
will stab, lance, burn or strangle that
person to feel as though you're a
virtuous hero.
And also what will happen is that the
pharaoh will then be um asked to be
Osiris and guess what the person will be
put in a tomb cut up and have sex with a
prostitute. Okay, pretending to be a
priest
and then Horus will be of course this.
Okay.
>> So, this is all to create trauma
which creates disassociation
which allows the priest to program the
pharaoh.
>> Okay. Does that make sense?
>> Okay. So,
how this works is while this is
happening, there's the the um pharaoh is
under a lot of trauma, but there's
always someone there to support the
pharaoh, and that's Isis, right? So,
there's a priest in the ISIS mask using
ISIS voice to calm the pharaoh, even
have sex with the pharaoh to make the
pharaoh dependent on Isis. And now Isis
becomes the controller.
the person that the pharaoh will always
trust. So if the priest ever want to
tell Pharaoh to do something, then late
at night while the pharaoh's sleeping or
on drugs, Isis wearing the mask can come
in and whisper the pharaoh what to do.
Okay?
And
in the system there are different ways
in which the priest can use to activate
the different identities. But the main
mechanism is smell.
Okay,
smell.
And what this means is that while all
this is happening, there are different
scents for different identities. Okay,
so for example with raw it might be
incense.
Okay, but with Osiris it might be
I don't know roses. Who knows? Okay. But
so what happens is when the pharaoh is a
throne room and the priest need the
pharaoh to make a certain decision, the
priest will let out different scents
which will activate different emotions
in the pharaoh which then determines how
the pharaoh will make the decision.
Okay? So there's different control
mechanisms.
Okay? And what's important for us to
understand is we're all like this,
right? Because for example
um we have different identities. At
school we're a student but at home we're
a child. We're outside we're friends.
We're a friend. When we're at work we're
an employee. So we behave differently
depending on the different circumstance.
And the circumstance activates a certain
emotion, certain identity, certain
behavior, certain actions in us. Okay.
So we're all programmable, but the
pharaoh has to be programmed to a
certain degree. Okay? So to better
understand this, let me give you an
example. Let's just say that you are the
best football player, the best soccer
player in the whole world. No one can
beat you. You're you're basically messy.
Okay?
But one day, for example, for whatever
reason, you wake up and you lose all
your memory. You forget what your name
is. You forget who your friends are. You
even forget that uh you play soccer. And
what's also really strange is the entire
world forgets that you play soccer.
Okay? So, you're just wandering around
and you have no idea who you are. And
you do this for like 10 years. Suddenly,
one day for for whatever reason, you're
on soccer field and someone kicks you a
ball and you kick it back. Would you
still be the best soccer player in the
world?
The answer is yes, you would be. Right?
Why? Because you've been trained. It's
muscle memory. It's in it's your
subconscious.
So that's the trick here. The trick is
to train you in a certain way
to make you a robot.
Okay. Is it possible for me to make
someone into a killer? Yes. Because what
I do is I make that person take a lot of
psychedelics and then train that person
to shoot someone with a gun. Okay? And
then while he's shooting that person, I
use the word acadabra.
So what happens is the person if he's
walking has a gun, all all they do is
use the word acadabra. Takes a gun and
shoots someone. Okay? All right. So
through programming, I can turn anyone
to a robot. I can turn someone anyone
into a sex robot, a killer robot, even a
sex killer robot. Okay? Okay, I can do
all this.
>> And that's this great secret here. All
right, so 5,000 years ago in Egypt, they
were doing this. And but again, okay,
it's what's really important is this is
all speculation. And it's really
important for you to doubt and question
me because we don't actually know that
this happened. All the records have been
lost to us. And obviously, this would be
the greatest state secret of Egypt. But
from my perspective, it makes sense
because the Pharaoh needs to be like
this in order to survive, right? Because
the Pharaoh has brothers who want his
throne. If he's a nice guy, guess what?
Dead, right?
So that's true for everyone in power. If
you're a nice person who feels sorry for
poor people, you're dead. Okay? So you
have to have certain characteristics in
order to be a great leader and the main
characteristic is dissociation.
So the pharaoh so the priests are
actually protecting the pharaoh. Okay,
>> does that make sense? All right. So what
I I know this is hard but I need you
guys to remember the story of Egyptian
mythology because we'll use it over and
over. Also, these techniques that they
use, uh, tombs, cutting you up, um, sex,
drowning, uh, rape are also techniques
that we still use today.
So, what they did in Egypt 5,000 years
ago, we still do today. There's
absolutely no difference. And I will
show you this as we move on. Okay. But
are there any questions so far? Yeah.
>> Sorry. Sorry. Sorry. Can you speak in
the microphone, please?
So they only trained the pharaoh by this
method and and not his relatives know
his brothers or something.
>> Okay, that's a great question. Okay,
that's a great question. So who's being
trained into this system? And the answer
is everyone, right? Because the people
really in control are the priests.
They're what what we today call the deep
state.
And it's possible the pharaoh gets gets
an accident and dies. Okay. So you need
someone right away to replace the
pharaoh. So everyone is being everyone
in the royal family is being trained
into this. The problem arises when the
priest class divides into different
political factions who all want power.
Then they program the pharaoh's brother
to create a civil war.
Okay. So everyone who who is in a royal
family is being programmed like this.
But then this raises a really
interesting question is like why would
they agree to this right now? What's
interesting is that
um these psychedelics and these uh
trauma create something called NDE.
Okay. What we call neardeath
experiences. So for like a minute or 10
minutes or or half an hour they are
literally dead. And what we know is when
that happens and and it's really
interesting is when you are feel you're
almost dead you transcend into the
spirit world. In the spirit world you
actually meet God. And we know this
because tens of thousands of people have
had an ND ND near-death experience. you
know, they got in a car crash and they
blacked out or they were drowning and
they almost died or they had a heart
attack and died. They all went to to
meet God and they all said up there in
the spirit world, it's all peaceful.
It's all love. You can feel God in you.
But God told me I cannot die. I have to
come back and tell people the true
spirit world. So the royal family does
this because it gives them wisdom and
access to the spirit world so that they
feel as though they're truly God.
Okay? And that's why they agree to do
this,
right? But then the question then is how
do the priests know how to do this?
because they they experiment on
themselves because they're priests and
they want to access the spirit world
themselves and they recognize that uh
near-death experiences and psychedelics
are the best two ways to go into that
world. So, they drown themselves, they
cut themselves up, um they starve
themselves, um there are lots of ways to
create near-death experiences, okay? But
but that's how they know the secrets.
And what's amazing is we have not
improved on Egyptians today. like all
the modern technology, all the modern
medicine, science, we're just doing what
they're doing. Okay. Okay. So, does it
make sense, guys?
>> Okay. Any more questions before I move
on?
>> So, there's
>> Okay.
>> There's no difference between heaven and
hell.
>> Sorry. Excuse me. There's no different
between heaven and hell because I mean
um
technically speaking if if you do bad
things you will never go to heaven but
uh and then when if you experience NE
and you still meet the spiritual world
then you'll realize that there's no
difference between heaven and hell.
>> Okay that that that's a great question.
Okay. So what is h heaven? What is hell?
Why should you do bad things? Why should
you do good things? You know, there's no
difference. Okay. So what people who
suffer NDE will tell you is this. You go
up to the spirit world, the first thing
that will happen is something called a
life review.
What is a life review? A life review is
this. You're able to see exactly what
you did your entire life. So if you're a
bad person, that's hell because you're
able to now feel pain for the first
time, right? Dissociation means you
don't feel any pain. But guess what?
You're just tricking yourself because
when you're up in the spirit world, you
have to see exactly what you did to
other people. You have to feel their
pain. Okay? That's what hell is. In
heaven is you can see the good that you
did. Okay? So what they say is that when
you do evil, you create negative energy
and when you do good, you create
positive energy. And you can't see that
in this world, but up in the spirit
world, you're able to see for yourself
finally how much evil you did and how
much good you did. Okay. And and that's
what heaven and hell is. Okay. And um I
mean I don't want to go too much into
this, but another another theory is that
um
when you die, the only thing that that
is that remains in you is love. Okay? So
love is actually a physical force. And
the more love you have, the higher you
can ascend in the spirit world. And the
less love you have, well, you're kind of
stuck and and you you have to come back
and do it again.
Okay. So, um, be a nice person. All
right. Okay. Great question. Okay. So,
so are we clear about this? Okay. Well,
we'll we'll discuss more about
near-death experiences later on in the
spirit world later on. Okay. But I I
want to I want you to understand that
5,000 years ago in Egypt, they
discovered how to program the feral into
a robot that they can control. And we
still use same techniques today. Okay.
Any questions before I move on?
All right. So, let's go to the PPT.
Okay. So, um as you can see,
as you can see in Egypt, it's the
priests who are willing control. The
pharaohs are just a puppets. Okay? And
it makes sense, right? Because one
person cannot control an entire empire.
It's the priests, the bureaucrats who
really have the power.
Okay, so we talk about dissociative
identity disorder, right? And you think,
wow, it's really great to have all this
power, but actually the one thing about
dissocive personality disorder is you
can never feel happiness.
In fact, you can only feel misery. So
the way to reduce your misery is by
making others more miserable than you
are.
>> Okay? Okay, so the people in power are
committed to making the world as evil
and as unhappy and as miserable as
possible because that's the only way
they can feel good about themselves.
Okay, so this is dissocive identity
disorder. Um, as you can see, it's
really bad. Okay, you have identity
confusion. You have changing memories,
flashbacks, uh, intrusive thoughts,
okay, internal voices. It's it's not a
great feeling to have this.
All right.
Sorry. What is going on here?
Oh, great.
Sorry.
Okay.
Okay. So now I want to talk about 911
and the war on terror. This is Donald
Rumsfield. And after 911, America
decided that they need to take
offensive. They need to hunt down the
terrorists and
control their behavior and so they start
to arrest terrorists.
But then bad things start to happen.
Okay. So this is a prison in Iraq, Abu
Grabi, where they arrested terrorists
and they were doing strange thing to
these terrorists as you can see.
Okay, so
this is pretty disgusting stuff. And
this was leaked to CBS News and CBS News
report like showed all this.
Okay.
All right. So, it's pretty disgusting.
So, now the question then is why is this
happening? And there they've been
different explanations. The military
says these are soldiers who went crazy
and they went rogue. So, we we've
arrested them and we punished them. But
then they discovered that they're
actually psychologists who were
responsible for this program. So, these
are two psychologists um and they were
sued by the victims and during the court
testimony we discovered that they were
paid $80 million by the CI CIA to
develop this program. So, what is going
on here? This is not something that
happened randomly. It was designed by
the government by the CIA. So, why is
this happening? Well, they call it
enhanced interrogation.
Okay,
this is a book, The Dark Side by Jay
Mir, who's a fantastic reporter. I I
highly recommend this book. Uh she's a
reporter for New Yorker and spent years
looking into why this torture happened.
And what she argued is it's an
experiment to change the mentality of
these terrorists.
And the theory is called learned
helplessness. You can basically take
someone like Rah, okay, the virtuous
hero and turn him to Osiris through
certain techniques. Okay, remember Rah,
the identity is the virtuous hero who
fights Opus every day. Osiris is a
person who gets tortured by Set every
day. Okay. So the goal of this
experiment is to turn Ra into Osiris.
[Music]
And the person who help learn
helplessness is also the person who
developed a new theory called
positive psychology.
His name is Martin Sigloman. Okay. So
positive psychology that you're learning
in school is brainwashing.
Okay.
All right. So that's a theory and it's a
great theory and this is what most
people believe. The problem though is it
doesn't actually work because after the
CIA started to torture all these
prisoners, they became ISIS, Islamic
State.
ISIS is the name of what? the Egyptian
goddess who saved Osiris, right? And who
father Horus. Do you think it's a
coincidence? Maybe not. Okay, maybe not.
So, ISIS is this fanatical death cult
that are terrorists who go around the
Middle East and kill a lot of people.
Okay, you might have seen their videos
where they do a lot of nasty stuff like
beheading people. Okay. So, what a lot
of people discovered is that there's
actually a
direct connection between sorry ISIS
and this torture. In fact,
in many academics, so for example,
Jeremy Suri and Andrew Thompson, they
discovered that many of the ISIS
fighters the US is currently combating
in the Middle East deep into extremism
during a time in prisons controlled by
the United States. So, it's really
strange. The United States thought that
they they were going to use the
psychology to train to turn Rah, the
terrorist, into Osiris, the citizen. But
they end up doing the reverse. Osiris
became rah. How stupid were they? Right?
And these guys were paid $80 million to
be stupid.
Okay, so this is human rights first, an
organization that start to interview
these prisoners of uh of of of America.
Okay. And what they discovered is these
prisoners told them sorry this okay
their testimony shows that ISIS
recruitment is still ongoing unchecked
by Egyptian authorities and field and
substantial part of the torture and
other abuse that pervade Egyptian
prisons. So it's really strange how
these prisons are almost training
ISIS terrorists.
What's going on?
Well,
let's go back to Guanton Bay. Okay, the
answer lies in these prisons and what
they doing there. So, most of these
prisoners were so traumatized they
forgot what happened. But we have one
man um Abu Zuba who remember what
happened. He's a Saudi citizen who was
captured and he told us what were they
what what they were doing to him. Okay.
So, we're going to go through your story
and you tell me what the story reminds
you of. So, they basically were
force-feeding him, torturing him,
strangling him.
Then they put him in a coffin and they
drown him.
Then they use a power drill to do this
to him. Okay. To basically cut him up.
Whoa. Do you guys remember the story?
>> Oh, and also sexual humiliation, right?
Where they had a woman who tried to
seduce him
also guys,
right? Do you guys see this?
>> What the story? What what what is the
story guys? What is the story?
It's a story of Egypt. This is what they
did to Pharaoh 5,000 years ago. It's the
same story. It's the same script. In
other words, they're not trying. What
they're really doing is they're trying
to turn these people who are mostly
innocent into terrorists. They're trying
to turn these people into drones that
they can program and unleash in the
Middle East. That's the real goal.
Okay. So, it wasn't that the experiment
failed. It worked.
ISIS is an American creation designed to
create as much chaos as possible in the
Middle East. Let me ask you this
question.
If you really wanted to get information
from these terrorists,
what's the best way to do that?
>> Pay the money. Be friends with them. Be
nice to them. Take them out to dinner.
Okay? We have lots of evidence to
suggest that if you just be nice to
these people, they'll tell you
everything they know. You don't have to
torture them. You torture them because
you're trying to turn them into secret
weapons to be unleashed
in the world. Okay.
All right. So
5,000 years ago, they were doing this to
Pharaoh and now they figure out how to
do this to anyone using drugs, using
torture,
using ritual abuse.
Okay, so all these ISIS fighters,
they're robots controlled by the
American military. They're drones, the
human drones used. Okay, why is this
important? It's important because
5,000 years ago, trying to control the
feral was first and foremost about
social control.
So,
so
there's a program called MK Ultra
started in the 1950s and60s led by a
chemist called Sydney Gobble. Okay? And
the point of MK Ultra was to figure out
how to brainwash people.
And for the longest time, this was
considered a conspiracy theory. But a
few years ago, the CIA, the US
government admitted, "We actually did
this." But not anymore. Okay? We did
this before, but not today. Not today.
Okay? Okay. So, if you're curious, there
are lots of there are lots of documents,
government documents,
um, on the internet that you can read.
Okay. But the NBA Ultra was a program
designed to test the effects of drugs
and brainwashing on innocent American
citizens, especially children.
Okay.
Um, so some of the documents that are
now public and and guys, just so you
know, most of the documentation, the
most sensitive documentation was
destroyed by the participants. So we
only have a few of the documents. But
some of the things that they were doing
was brainwashing, okay? Using drugs,
hypnosis in order to control people's
minds, okay, interrogation techniques.
Um, they were working with foreign
intelligence officials to conduct mind
control research. Okay, so the things
you couldn't do in the United States
legally, they were doing in Egypt, which
created what guysa.
Okay. Um, they were also doing things
that were really weird. For example,
they they started a brothel. And so if
you came to the brothel, they gave you
drugs,
okay? Like LSD. And they were trying to
figure out how to control your mind.
But they won't do this to most people,
right? Okay. Well, I'll show you later
on. Um, you'll be surprised.
Okay. Okay, so this is Sime Gobbley and
he was the man responsible for MK Ultra
and he's a chemist. Okay, so he's trying
to figure out how to use these drugs to
control the population. And you're like,
well, this is just weird. And if you
talk to experts, like, well, the MK
Ultra results were terrible. But then
ask yourself this. What is social media?
What is if if you feel bad and you go to
a doctor and the doctor gives you drugs,
how do they know these drugs work? Okay,
so MK Ultra did work, but they they they
were they hide the fact of its
effectiveness and the results of MK
Ultra have spread throughout society.
Guys, good news. You're now the pharaoh.
Okay, each and every one of you are now
the pharaoh. Congratulations. Something
really funny about psychologist is this.
Sorry, I'm just Why is this happening?
Okay, you may not know this, but
psychologists have been known to have a
greater propensity to have mental
illness than most people. Your
psychologist is literally more screwed
up in the brain than you are. Okay, you
don't believe me? Do some research. And
this is really weird because
if you went to a doctor and the doctor
was fat and unhealthy,
that' be that'd be problematic, right?
Um, also
I have not met anyone who's gotten
better psychologically after seeing a
psychologist. You guys might have and
I'm sure there are lots and lots of
people who benefited from seeing a
psychologist, but I myself have never
met anyone or seen anyone who's benefit
from seeing a psychologist. That's
really weird because if you break your
leg and you go to a doctor and like for
years and years doesn't get better,
well, that's a problem, right? Okay. So,
um something to keep something to keep
in mind. Okay. So, any questions?
questions guys.
So I I know this was a lot to take in
um and we'll be expanding these topics
as we move on. Okay. But some key
takeaways is
all societies are first and foremost
concerned with social control.
And what's really interesting is who we
are as a human being has not changed in
thousands of years. So that the way the
way they were controlling the pharaoh in
Egypt 5,000 years ago is still is really
the way that they control us today. And
I'll show you how as we discuss mass as
the mass media, okay, and mass education
and mass psychology. Okay. Um we have a
question here.
In that case, shouldn't the social media
be controlled by government? Like for
example, why Twitter and or say X could
be
a personal thing by owned by Elon Musk?
>> Okay, that's a great question. Okay, so
if it's true that social media is a
mechanism for social control, why are
they being controlled by private
citizens who've made billions of dollars
doing it? Right? Okay. Well, let me ask
you this question. Who built the
internet?
You guys do you guys know who built the
internet? The US military, right?
Because the internet is is um controlled
by these cables that run around the
world. Who who who built all these
cables? The US military. Do you think
they would do this for free? Why would
they do this? Okay. So, Twitter,
Facebook, that's the public face. Okay.
What what people forget is behind
Facebook and Twitter are all the this
infrastructure that's being controlled
and protected by the US military. So why
would why would the military do this?
Okay?
Right? And again,
this is a class about speculation, about
theories. Okay? I'm not telling you
what's true. I'm I'm just raising
questions and possibilities about what's
really going on. Okay. And also like
um
I don't know what they did in Egypt
5,000 years ago. I'm just speculating.
It's just a theory. It's a nice theory,
but I have no evidence that it's true.
Okay. This is just a disclaimer. Take
what I say with a grain of salt. Be
skeptical and doubtful of what I say.
All right. Okay. Any more questions?
Okay, great. Okay, so I'll I'll see you
guys next class.